the general public was not seeing what i
was seeing because these were all
private pages so these are not things
that would go viral
and the only time the fbi the police or
like facebook really got involved is
when one of those videos broke out of
those private pages and then it got
mainstream
there was an instance i remember
specifically of um
these two girls and they were
babysitting these kids and they were
forcing the toddlers and babies to smoke
marijuana and that one went viral
and i remember facebook came in with
their team we actually had the local
police from that area work with us and
we were able to identify them and
apprehend those two
so that would be one of those rare
instances where we actually did do
something
but it only really happened because it
went mainstream because it went viral
and a lot of the content i dealt with
just never became viral because it was
in these isolated pockets
uh just
to go on a little bit more about that
with um a lot of this content especially
the graphic violence stuff facebook had
this incredibly weird policy where
a lot of abuse whether towards children
animals adults
they would leave it on there
and they would tell us they would leave
it on there because they would say that
either a good samaritan or a police
officer would see that content
and they would like
give a lead to who that person was
and so their idea was we're just going
to leave it on there so hopefully a good
samaritan will give us some info and
then they can get justice to them what
do you think about that
it's a lie because the police don't have
our systems
the police aren't looking at what we're
looking at they don't have they don't
have the software that facebook has to
actually look at the type of content
that we're looking at
and i wish i realized that when i was in
training instead of believing it and
thinking that i was making
a change and trying to like
help these people and animals even if
they're already dead as long as like
their final moments aren't being
desecrated in these videos and pictures
and i really did believe that
somehow good samaritans or police were
actually going to help
see this content report on it say who it
was in there
but those people aren't seeing it
only i'm seeing it
so so let me ask you so
sometimes when you run a big company
you
don't really know
what's going on everywhere right i mean
uh
so you know facebook's got give or take
60 000 employees
that's a pretty big organization they
got some sites say they get 1.87 billion
unique visitors per month some sites say
they get two and a half
to 2.8 billion unique visitors per month
users per month okay whatever the number
is let's say 2 billion that's a lot of
people that come to their website on a
monthly basis
so you got 60 000 plus employees you got
2 billion users actively that are
logging on to your website you're you're
the largest country in the world
essentially china's got one and a half
billion india's got 1.4 1.5 billion you
got two billion you're a country you're
a virtual government
do you think this stuff is stuff that
maybe
it's so far away from zuck's hands that
he doesn't even know this this stuff is
taking place
no he knows what's taking place because
his hands are all in it like this is his
creation and as we've seen through his
multiple appearances with congress and
the way he speaks in any sort of
interviews
he obviously presents himself presents
himself as someone that has his hands
and all the all the pies so to speak
um what i think is the problem is one he
facebook has grown too big and needs to
be cut down into sizable chunks maybe
they need to be operated by different
individuals that are not affiliated with
him
but the biggest problem i had was just
the reallocation of resources was
terrible there was so
i talked a little bit about this ai that
we were using that was trying to help
with graphic content
what the i ai was primarily being used
for was looking at sexually suggestive
photos not even photos that were sexual
not even photos that showed anything
it wasn't any pornographic images
so examples like if there's a picture of
a girl and she has her butt sticking out
in the photo she's wearing all clothes
the ai needed to know if that was a butt
focus picture or not or
a lot of the times we would just look at
the pictures and we would just identify
if something was cleavage as in the
indentation between the breasts
that was cleavage there was another one
of identifying women in swimsuits
there was another one that identified
nipple
or areola so we actually had to train
the ai to look at something and see if
they could just identify the areola
around the nipple
so this is what a lot of the ai
resources were going to not graphic
violence not child pornography
not any of these terrible things it was
going towards these
sexually suggestive photos and videos
and it was just a terrible use of the ai
there was absolutely no need to teach an
ai how to categorize that content
because none of that content was
breaking any policy
because even though we were working with
it we were never actioning that content
because there was nothing ever wrong
with the content for some reason they
just wanted that categorized so if you
like this sort of short clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]